votre unité est plus que jamais
nécessaire ce sont les mots de
l'émissaire de l'onu pour la birmanie
christine schraner burgener ce vendredi
l'organisation des nations unies se
rassembler pour un conseil de sécurité à
huis clos
une réunion qui vise à prendre des
mesures suite au putsch militaire du 1er
février dernier
des négociations sont attendus dans la
semaine sur un projet de texte
britannique
l'émissaire de l'onu s'est exprimé face
aux médias et souhaite une réponse ferme
de la part du conseil de sécurité
le devons faire preuve de fermeté et
d'opportunisme pour pousser à l'arrêt de
la violence et au rétablissement des
institutions démocratiques en birmanie
nous devons dénoncer les actions des
militaires qui continuent de porter
gravement atteinte au principe de cette
organisation et ignorent nos signaux
clairs pour les faire respecter
en effet ce mercredi au moins 38
personnes ont été tuées lors des
manifestations en soutien à aung san suu
kyi emprisonnée depuis le 1er février
des milliers de birmans défilent dans
les rues
les affrontements avec l'agente ne
cessent de se multiplier
l'ambassadrice du royaume uni auprès des
nations unies a évoqué les sanctions
contre la birmanie dans le but de
sauvegarder les aspirations
démocratiques du peuple birman comme le
royaume-uni condamne les âges de la
violence contre des manifestants
pacifiques appelle à la cessation
immédiate de la violence et demande que
les responsables soient tenus de rendre
des côtes en collaboration avec ses
partenaires
le royaume uni a récemment sanctionné
neuf officiers militaires dont le
commandant en chef pour leur rôle dans
le coup d'état
nous allons étudier d'autres sanctions
nationales et nous sommes prêts à
envisager des mesures possibles dans le
cadre de la charte des nations unies
chante si la situation devait se
détériorer davantage
or ce vendredi les manifestations
pacifiques continué dans plusieurs
villes du pays malgré les appels à la
paix un des ces deux puces est à
déplorer à l'issue de cette nouvelle
journée de protestation